these are the most desperate times in
Venezuela we've told you here on this
show the economy is essentially
collapsing and poverty is skyrocketing
there that is leading many Venezuelans
to abandon hope and leave correspondent
rich Edson tells us about it tonight
from the State Department desperate for
food and medicine thousands of
Venezuelans cross into neighboring
Colombia but are not so dumb of Mordovia
we are starving regretfully Venezuela is
starving we are dying of hunger all of
Venezuela Venezuela has practically
already collapsed they're sleeping on
the streets one making hand crafts from
Venezuelan currency because these bills
really aren't being accepted anywhere
anymore the bills practically aren't
worth anything anymore
it's just simple paper the international
monetary fund projects inflation in
Venezuela to rise 13,000 percent this
year while its economy shrinks 15% with
economic conditions deteriorating
dramatically food and medicine are
scarce more than 4 in 10 Venezuelans
want to leave their country permanently
Gallup says it conducted that poll late
last year as families scavenged for food
in garbage bags and violence and hunger
overcame the country his country now in
crisis President Nicolas Maduro says he
is still pursuing reelection in May
North America Syrian we're under
pressure but Venezuela moves based on
principles it moves based on its
constitution the United States calls
that May 20th the election illegitimate
and says it's considering more sanctions
on the Maduro government we have seen
the repeated elections that have had
where the regime has pushed people to
vote a certain way provided monetary
encouragement to vote a certain way our
concerns still remain about the erosion
of democracy in that country and it is
now more difficult for Venezuelans to
escape their home country Colombia has
tightened migration and border controls
I hope to god they don't deport me and I
don't want to go back to Venezuela right
now I don't know when I'll go back but
not right now I plan to stay here
working to achieve a better life for my
children mais presidential election
results seems almost predetermined
president Nicolas Maduro 'he's main
opposition's boy
the vote they say he's rigged the system
and they refuse to participate and lend
the perception of legitimacy to this
election
Brett rich adds another state department
rich thank you